[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me trouve avec tara bengué villa
beaux jours bonjour alors vous êtes chef
pilote adjointe de l'aéro club de
versailles derrière nous on a des avions
oui ce sont des avions sont pas des ulm
non ce sont effectivement des avions il
faut savoir c'est une association donc
que l'aéro club il a été créé en 1911 on
1 150 membres dont 50 élèves pilotes on
essaie instructeur avec 3 mécano et
justement on vole sur cinq avions que
vous pouvez voir à peu près ici
[Musique]
on a 3 robin dr 400 et 2 sont à coeur de
sang essentiellement pour de
l'instruction est donc parmi ces 50
élèves est-ce que c'est plus du loisir
est ce que c'est vraiment pour se former
professionnellement dai a un peu des
deux je dirais 50 50 il y en a qui sont
là effectivement pour de la formation
professionnelle et d'autres c'est plutôt
pour le plaisir pour s'amuser et c'est
si c'est un pépé aide c'est un minimum
réglementaire de 45 heures de vol alors
pété lc oui c'est une liste pardon c'est
une licence privée de pilotes d'accord
et 1 et l'apl c'est une licence près des
deux pilotes des ondes avions légers
d'accord voilà donc ppl c'est une
carence et 45 heures de vol
réglementaire minimum et le l apn c'est
une trentaine d'heures de vol
réglementairement et vous proposer aussi
des initiations en des baptêmes de l'air
oui pour vraiment là c'est grand public
grand public tout à fait donc on a dit
ce qu'on appelle des vols de découverte
c'est une trentaine
une itt de vol
sur un vol local avec
un pilote breveté on a aussi des vols
d'initiation à ce moment là c'est trente
minutes de vol dans un cadre de
l'instruction avec un instructeur où on
prend vraiment les commandes et on
s'initie à la vda sont légères et du
coup vous êtes aussi instructrice
puisque vous allez partir pendant une
heure avec un élève actuellement avec
mon élève on est sur la partie
navigation sur ce trajet aller retour on
va voir quelques exercices bien
évidemment on fera des exercices de
déroutement auprès des exercices de
pannes mois d'exercice de déroutement le
déroutement c'est quand par exemple
on voit que la météo se dégradent que
l'ami aeronautica arrive qu'on peut pas
arriver à destination on change notre
trajet on faisait route sur un autre
aérodrome eh ben je vous laisse faire
votre cours et puis on se retrouve après
bercy
[Musique]
je me trouve avec claude ça y est il est
prêt à partir en cours avec sarah depuis
combien de temps êtes vous êtes élève
ici à l'aéro club de versailles claude
cela fait trois ans que je suis au co
l'aéro club de versailles
progressivement j'évolue dans le mail du
vol qu'on va aboutir à décrocher la
licence et pourquoi cette passion pour
l'aviation passion pour l'aviation en
réalité je réalise un rêve un rêve
d'enfance voilà il n'est jamais trop
tard super et ben vous laisse faire
votre séance et puis bon on espère que
ça va se passer ça va bien se passer
normalement si vous volez ben bon vol
que des sarts à merci
[Musique]
voilà claude a bien pris son envol site
à vous a donné aussi envie de vous
initier à l'aviation sachez qu'un cours
de vol est à partir de 137 euros et le
baptême de l'air est aussi à 135 euros
mais vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet
aéroclub tirer versailles point com
[Musique]